le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux très
haut commissaire à la réforme des
retraites
vous travaillez depuis deux ans monsieur
le ministre à une réforme des retraites
et la semaine dernière encore vous avez
été désavoué par le président de la
république
quant au modèle que vous proposiez vous
aviez annoncé un aboutissement de la
réforme avant les municipales puis après
les municipales ce qui est plus sage
puis maintenant ça semble repoussée aux
calendes grecques
vous nous avez proposé de passer d'un
système de répartition un système de
points vous avez annoncé la fin des
régimes spéciaux mais on apprend par la
presse que ça tangue au sein du
gouvernement
vous avez dit vous même que l'option
d'une réforme des régimes spéciaux pour
les nouveaux entrants n'était pas votre
tasse de thé elle était celle du
président en vérité une seule chose
semble sûre c'est que vous avez fait le
choix de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des retraités puisque les pensions ne
seront pas rêver la risée en 2020 allons
monsieur le ministre croit que le temps
le temps est venu de tomber les masques
de regarder les français dans les yeux
de leur dire la vérité sans en même
temps permanent sans en même temps en
permanence ménager la chèvre et le chou
peut-être craignez vous de revivre les
grèves de 95
j'ai donc deux questions êtes vous prêt
à proposer la suppression est immédiate
des régimes spéciaux l'alignement des
régimes du public sur ceux du privé sans
décaler la réforme
quitte à introduire un peu de
progressivité dans cette réforme
deuxièmement et vous prêt à reconnaître
que notre système de répartition ne peut
être maintenue que si il ya un
allongement de la durée de cotisation du
fait simplement de l'espérance de vie
qui s'allonge et du ratio qui s'aggrave
en permanence entre bénéficiaires et
cotisants merci monsieur liste